take your five best friends why do you
like them just write down those
qualities and you will find there's no
quality there that you bet you can't
have yourself how do I actually do it
how do i execute what are the next steps
I'm gonna give you the three next steps
you need to follow unless you are good
to other people around you unless you
are kind and friendly and warm and
loving you're not gonna enjoy this life
rise and shine it's in spresso time
what's up believe nation it's evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have Michael Jordan level
talent at something and I want you to
find it embrace it and use it to make a
difference in the world so let's start
your day off right
grab your coffee and sip on today's
message be the person you want to be
over to you Warren Buffett if you look
around you at the people you admire you
know they have certain qualities I mean
you've got you've got friends why do you
like them you know generally you know
that they generally they have an upbeat
attitude on life generally they are
generous people there are humorous
people there are people that do more
than their share there are people that
are thinking about something nice they
can do for you and all of those
qualities attract you and none of those
are are innate at birth I mean you you
can acquire those and then there's other
people to turn you off you know and they
have habits they take credit for things
they didn't do they don't show up on
time whatever it may be they're little
dishonest about things and if you're
looking at your life at a young age like
you are and you can choose what kind of
a person you can be why not be the
person you admire rather than the person
you can't stand it so simple so just
write down the qualities you like to
take you to take your five best friends
why do you like them and just write down
those qualities and you will find
there's no quality there that you can't
have yourself and similarly with the
five people you can't stand to be around
put those put those things down the turn
you off about those people and if they
turn you off about them why should you
possess them because it's so simple you
know it's not it's
it's not like something complicated that
you think you should be learning as
investing in the stock market it's it's
enormous ly important to have people
work with you in life they're gonna work
with you in life if they like you you
know and they may occasionally I mean if
you're in the army or something you know
you may work for somebody that you don't
like but by-and-large
you're gonna get the best out of people
if they feel good about you and it's
just so easy but you've got to develop
the habits early because you can't say
I'm gonna suddenly become a terribly
attractive person when I'm 60 it just
doesn't work that way
so pick up the right habits now and I
will guarantee you if you actually just
write down those qualities and think
about it
you will find you can have every one of
the attractive qualities get rid of the
ones that are are negative and your life
will be different self-awareness is the
unlock if you are struggling if you know
that there's another degree above you
you know there's another world that you
should be playing in your life may not
suck but you know you're capable of more
a lot of it comes down to self-awareness
you just don't know yourself enough you
just don't know the kind of person that
you want to be enough you know that
you're not where you want to be you know
that people around you not the people
that you want to have around you but you
don't know enough about where you want
to go so I wrote the book your one word
it's figuring out what your single most
important core value is and then
building a life and a business around it
if you don't know what your most
important core value is then you're
gonna be living the life that other
people want you to live you're gonna be
living the life your parents want you to
live or your friends want you to live
and that may even be 75% of the life you
actually want to live that's good but
it's not great you know you can do more
you know there's another degree up there
that you haven't reached yet and so to
figure that out you have to understand
what your core values are so whether you
use your one word whether you use Warren
Buffett's method of looking at your five
friends and what you love about them or
the five people you hate and what you
hate about them and adjusting and making
that list it's really really really
really really really really really
important for you to get the
self-awareness then the next question
becomes okay I know what I want to do I
know what I want to be I know the person
I want to become and who I don't want to
hang around anymore how do I actually do
it how do i execute what are the next
steps I'm gonna give you the three next
steps you need to follow something
one is making important this future
South that you want to build this ideal
self this this person who was believed
or your one word or the the five things
from your friends like that person you
want to become has to be important
especially if it's just good if your
life is just good right now it's really
hard to give up good to go for great if
your life sucked it'd be easy if you've
hit rock bottom it's easy to want to
make the change cuz your life is just
total garbage right now so it's easier
but when your life is good it's
comfortable and it's really hard to
break out of that comfort zone so you
have to make it important and the way
that I do it is I make the future beer
of regret
ginormous look at what it is right now
where you're at the good vs. the great
on the day to day basis you may not feel
it much but project forward until your
age 90 or 190 however long we'll be
living at that point look at all of
those years from now until when you're
gonna die imagine you just live in a
good life instead of a great one imagine
if you look at where you're right now
versus what you could be what you aspire
to be and you just stayin here instead
of playing out here for the rest of your
life make that as painful as possible
and I use that as a kick forward not
down I use it as a kick forward to say I
need to get my act together I need to
get in gear I need to make this really
really important that change has to
happen right now
as opposed to just saying well you know
I I can one day get there and be super
patient with yourself make it important
make it matter and it will force you
into action okay we've made an important
now how do we actually do it number two
change your environment you are a
reflection of your environment forever
in always your belief system your
mindset your limitations are a
reflection of the environment that you
now choose to surround yourself with and
growing up you may not have had a lot of
choices you know the parents were your
parents and where you grew up was where
you grew up the the city your aim as a
city you're in and all of that but as
you get older you get to choose at some
point you get to say hey if my
environments not surfing me I get to
choose to make a better one I get to
choose to surround myself with things
that make me come alive look at the
things that are on your list whether you
use Warren's five or your one word
whatever it is the person that you want
to be think about is that in your
environment enough are there people in
your life who are helping you become
that if it's not people is it your
physical environment
right for me it's believed my one word
is believed everything I do is about
belief hopefully in this video it's
oozing believe belief in you and your
ability to do amazing things and me the
warm buff of your industry I believe I
love it
how do I stay believe every day how do I
push for more believe every day it
starts with my physical environment this
these people you know they may not mean
a lot to you but they mean something to
me each one of these pictures tell me a
story when you change your physical
environment you only have to do it once
but you walk into it and it's a mindset
shift every single time I come into my
office these people help me believe more
the content that you consume this video
here the sense press it was for me
Warren Buffett's message is a reminder
to myself and I share it with you guys I
guarantee you if you love Warren Buffett
if you surrounded yourself with Warren
Buffett every single day if you liked
his optimism his way of thinking his
mindset you surround yourself with
Warren Buffett videos every single
morning that's how you start your day
you start your day with intention not by
accident you start your day with Warren
Buffett content you will change your
mindset will be different you will act
in a different way you will carry
yourself in a different way your
standards will be raised in a different
way than what you were expecting because
now Warren Buffett is one of your best
friends instead of who your former best
friend was and it doesn't mean you need
to cut out tons of people from your
environment it may mean that but even
limiting access a little bit or cutting
off access to Netflix or binge watching
documentaries or Big Brother or whatever
reality TV show and bringing in Warren
Buffett and other people who you look up
to and respect just doing that starting
your day with that every morning will
shift how you think if you understand
the person that you want to be the core
values that you espouse that that's
that's what you want to look like then
surrounding yourself with the people who
have done it who have achieved that and
digesting it eating it eating it every
single day will get you closer to that
it's why I started the top 10 series
it's why do the men to me series the
more you can hang around those people
the more they're thinking their beliefs
their mindset is gonna seep into you to
help you become the same way and number
three is checking regularly you have a
plan the plan doesn't always work you
know you want to be these five things
that one thing you have a plan to do it
you're surrounding yourself with guys
like Warren Buffett maybe Warren Buffett
doesn't serve you anymore maybe
ultimately you've decided that it's
changing that he's not the best
representation maybe you don't like my
content anymore maybe
not serving you anymore great adjust we
may have these parallel paths for a
certain amount of time whether it's one
video one day one month one year ten
years a hundred years right whatever
that parallel path is I'm honored to be
a part of your journey and it's amazing
but if you need to jump off and go off
and do something else because that's in
your best interest and my videos don't
serve you anymore
amazing go do that stop watching and go
do that thing instead you need to be
constantly in tune with are the actions
that you're taking still supporting you
becoming that person that you want to be
and as long as they are then you keep
going and if not then you need to adjust
and so whenever something feels off in
your life when whenever something feels
like it's not right
I immediately look at my calendar look
at the actions that you're taking maybe
those videos don't serve you in a
morning anymore
maybe that podcast is gone stay on
doesn't give you the same emotions
before it's okay tweaked tweak'd tweaked
tweak'd tweaked to tweak your schedule
will never be the same it won't be the
same as it was a year ago five years ago
ten years ago maybe three months ago
maybe last week be open to changing and
adjusting as you change and adjust as a
human being now I've got a really
special bonus clip for you that I think
you're going to enjoy but before that
question of the day I want to know
what's the biggest change that you want
to make in your life who was the person
that you want to be that you haven't
quite become yet what needs to change in
your habits and your values in your
ideas what needs to change leave in the
comments below and by writing it down
you're making a commitment to actually
changing when you write it down you're
much more likely to actually follow
through so leave it in the comments
thank you guys so much for watching I
believe in you I hope we continue to
believe in yourself and whatever you're
one where it is much love I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
of espresso and enjoy the bonus clip
this pray so give me go
I just gotta ask this question the other
day young construction business and a
kid we were in a big meeting with a with
a bunch of leadership foremen two
engineers all in the same room bunch of
great guys from a great company and one
of the young engineers raised his hand
and said you know I'm young and I am
gonna be in charge of these guys you
know I'm not sure I'm comfortable with
these guys had been doing it for a lot
longer what can I do to you know gain
their respect and I said okay who in
this room knows more than that engineer
back there about construction and all
these salty construction Foreman's
raised their hands and I said who you
know who's gonna think that this guy's
got the best idea raise your hands my
hands go down and I said so this is what
you're dealing with
buddy I said now let me ask another
question the group group if this kid
comes in and says I know how to do this
better than you listen to me and do it
my way who's gonna have respect for him
raise your hand no hands go up if this
young kid comes in and says hey I'm an
engineer I've been educated but I
haven't been doing this for long can you
give me some recommendations on how we
do this so we can do the best job
possible who's gonna have respect for
him everyone raises their hand so there
you have it you you you don't have to
know everything as a leader no one
expects you know everything especially
as a young leader that's okay and
actually when you admit that you
actually gained respect when you ask for
people's input you actually gain respect
people get the paranoid feeling that if
they don't know something they're gonna
be seen as weak it's not true so you can
just step up into the position still be
humble still take advice now this
doesn't mean that you're a pushover
right this doesn't mean that you just
listen to what everyone says you don't
make any decisions no but it actually
means that you show respect to their
experience and when it comes time to
make a decision you get the best input
and then you make a decision and you
explain your decision and if your
decision is wrong you admit it and if
it's not wrong you push forward it's
good to treat other people the way you
would like to be treated yourself it's
like a golden rule and there's a reason
for and that
is that we're connected in some strange
way that we don't totally understand
unless you are good to other people
around you unless you are kind and
friendly and warm and loving you're not
gonna enjoy this life you're just not
you're gonna be problems everywhere you
go you're gonna have problems everywhere
you go you got to figure out a way to
enjoy life it's not because of Jesus
it's not because of Moses it's not
because of anybody that may or may not
have ever existed it's because that's
how you fit in better in the world
that's how you stay positive and it
doesn't have to be that was written 5000
years ago on animal skins that doesn't
have to be the golden rule because it's
old
you know that's dumb we need to figure
out like now today what what is you know
the best way to live your life what is
that you know there's got to be ways you
can be putting forward the most positive
energy I mean we know objectively what's
causing pollution we know objectively
what's causing birth defects and you
know and what are we're taking in too
much chemicals and not enough vitamins
we know objectively all this stuff we
know how to organize our world and yet
we don't do it we know how to organize
our health and yet very few people do it
we know all these things the right path
to like being like a happy healthy
person is to do all that we already know
you're supposed to do take care of your
body take care of your health take care
of your mind your stress meditate be
kind to people we all know that you mean
you ask anybody they know how to get by
and to be the the the most evolved
version of you that you can be I mean
it's not like a magical checklist if you
talk to people about it you said okay
here you got a person you want to
improve them what are the things you're
gonna do to them okay well if I was a
life coach the first thing I would say
is this guy's got to get on a diet that
makes them healthy I don't mean a diet
just to lose weight I mean just healthy
foods in your body mmm many many
vegetables vegetables a lot of good good
quality protein a lot of water stop the
sodas stop the bull start working out
your body and get a better sense of like
how this machine feels when it's moving
it's flowing better there's less tension
in it your mind feels like relaxed and
you enjoy every single moment of the day
better
step one everybody knows that step right
what's step two be cool to people be
nice to as many people as you can smile
of as many people as you can have them
smile back at you tip well when you go
to restaurants just do the most you can
be as nice as you can you know and just
still manage to not have people walk all
over you just get through this life it's
nice as you can what else
do what you want to do with your life
right don't don't go be doing something
you don't enjoy don't do something
that's don't get locked into you know a
car that you can't afford and doing
something crazy because you need the
money don't don't do that do what you
want to do because if someone else is
doing it you can do it you know I mean
everybody makes their own path through
this world but a lot of people don't
follow the path that they really feel
pulled to you know there's for whatever
reason they got negative programming you
know when they were kids someone told
them that couldn't do it or told them to
take the shortcut or or take the the
shore route that's a sad thing man when
you talk to dudes especially like
talented dudes and they don't follow up
with what they want to do you know if
you tell yourself a story long enough
you start to believe it don't you
believe it act like Tulsa what a whale
out of handcuffed lightning though
Thunder in jail now you know I'm bad
over the last week I've murdered a rock
into the stone hospitalized a brick I'm
so mean I make medicine sick the
fundamental key to success is it can
take between 18 and 250 four days of
taking action for a new habit to stick
I've created a new course called 250 for
confidence or every single day for 250
four days I will be sending you a video
between 30 seconds and 5 minutes long
that you start your morning with around
making you feel confident it's
absolutely free check out the link in
the description below to get access